one of the great intellectual puzzles
that daily life forces all of us to
consider on a slightly too regular basis
is
why are other people so awful how come
they're so unreliable aggressive
deceitful mean two-faced or cowardly as
we search for answers we tend quite
naturally to fall back on a standard
compact and tempting explanation because
they're terrible people they're
appalling crooked deformed or bad and
that's simply how some types are the
conclusion may be grim but it also feels
very true and fundamentally unbudgeable
however when things feel especially
clear-cut we may be goaded to try out an
unusual thought experiment which stands
to challenge a great many of our
certainties and render the world
usefully more complicated
we can try to look at our fellow human
beings through the eyes of love
the experiment requires particular
stamina and is best attempted at quieter
less agitated times of day
when we manage it it can count as one of
our highest ethical achievements
we are normally resolutely on our own
side deeply invested in our own point of
view and prone to trade in settled and
moralizing certainties yet very
occasionally we have the strength to
look at other people through a different
lens
we notice that their reality is likely
to be far more complicated and nuanced
than we first expected and the contrary
to our impulses they may be deserving of
more sympathy and consideration than we
thought even though they might have hurt
or frustrated us even though their
behavior might run contrary to what we
expect and even though the temptation is
always to call them idiots and numb
skulls and move on
looking at another person through the
eyes of love involves some of the
following steps
imagination
moralistic thinking identifies people
closely with their worst moments
love thinking pushes us in another
direction it bids us to use our
imaginations to picture why someone
might have done a regrettable deed and
yet could remain a fitting target for a
degree of understanding and sympathy
perhaps they got very frightened maybe
they were under pressure of extreme
anxiety or despair
those who look with love guess that
there will be sorrow and regret beneath
the furious rantings or a sense of
intolerable vulnerability behind the
pomposity and snobbishness
they intimate that early trauma and
letdown must have formed the backdrop to
later transgressions
they will remember that the person
before them was once a baby too
the loving interpreter holds onto the
idea that sweetness must remain beneath
the surface along with the possibility
of remorse and growth they are committed
to mitigating circumstances to any bits
of the truth that could cast a less
catastrophic light on folly and
nastiness
the child within
to consider others with love means
forever remembering the child within
them our wrongdoer may be fully grown
but their behavior will always be
connected up with their early years we
overlook the need occasionally to ignore
the outward adult sides of others in
order to perceive and sympathize with
the angry confused infant lurking inside
when we're around small children who
frustrate us we don't declare them evil
we don't bear down on them to show how
misguided they are we find less alarming
ways of grasping how they've come to say
or do certain things
we probably think they're getting a bit
tired or their gums are sore or they're
upset by the arrival of a younger
sibling we've got a large repertoire of
alternative explanations ready in our
heads
this is the reverse of what tends to
happen around adults here we imagine
that other people have deliberately got
us in their sights
but if we employ the infant model of
interpretation our first assumption
would be quite different given how
immature every adult necessarily remains
some of the moves we execute with
relative ease around children must
forever continue to be relevant when
we're dealing with another grown-up
patience
moralistic thinkers reach their
certainties swiftly
love thinkers take their time they
remain serene in the face of obviously
unimpressive behavior a sudden loss of
temper a wild accusation a very mean
remark they reach instinctively for
reasonable explanations and have clearly
in their minds the better moments of a
currently frantic but essentially
lovable person
redeeming features
love thinkers interpret everyone as
having strengths alongside their obvious
weaknesses when they encounter these
weaknesses they don't conclude that this
is all there is they know that almost
everything on the negative side of a
ledger could be connected up with
something on the positive they search a
little more assiduously than is normal
for the strength to which a maddening
characteristic must be twinned
we can see easily enough that someone is
pedantic and uncompromising but we tend
to forget at moments of crisis their
thoroughness and honesty we may know so
much about a person's messiness we
forget their uncommon degree of creative
enthusiasm there is no such thing as a
person with only strengths but nor is
there someone with only weaknesses the
consolation comes in refusing to view
defects in isolation
love is built out of a constantly
renewed and gently resigned awareness
that weakness-free people do not exist
we are sinners too
the single greatest spur towards a
loving perspective on others is a live
awareness that we are also deeply
imperfect and at points quite plainly
mad
the enemy of generosity is the sense
that we might be beyond fault whereas
love begins when we can acknowledge that
we are in equal measures idiotic
mentally wobbly and flawed it's an
implicit faith in their own perfection
that turns some people into such harsh
judges
looking at the world through the eyes of
love we're forced to conclude that there
is no such thing as a simply bad person
and no such thing as a monster there is
only ever pain anxiety and suffering
that have coalesced into unfortunate
action
we're not just being kind in this notion
this isn't merely an exercise in being
nice it's an exercise in getting to know
the truth of things which may when we
get down to the details of human
psychology be roughly and almost
coincidentally the same thing
to learn more about love try our book on
how to find love which explains why we
have the types we do and how our early
experiences shape how and whom we love
you